in 2016 Matt Damon was seen for the
fourth time in his role as Jason Bourne
neither the box of his results nor the
critics however let us hope that we will
see more of the action series in the
future so it's all the more surprising
that after four parts with Damon and one
part with Jeremy Renner they are now
working on a sixth part this was
revealed by producer Ben Smith who is
also working on the series Treadstone
based on the Bourne films and series the
title is still secret but you can be
sure that in Bourne 6 there will be
connecting elements between the series
and the film's when asked about the
return of Matt Damon or Jeremy Renner
however he remained silent until further
announcements are made the series
Treadstone remains to be seen in which
ten episodes sealed with brainwashing
which turns normal people around the
globe into killer machines in the USA
the series starts on 15th of October a
recently released Instagram video makes
Fast & Furious fans prick up their ears
Dwayne Johnson uploaded a contribution
thanking not only his entire crew for
working on Hopson Shaw but surprisingly
his rival windi's less well and at the
same time suggesting and return to the
main series the fact that the two fast
and furious actors weren't exactly best
friends has been known for quite some
time that's why there was the spin-off
helps ensure without win diesel while
the rest of the crew was working on Fast
and Furious 9 now the surprising
reconciliation seems like it because
Johnson emphasizes in his video how much
it meant to him that diesel
congratulated him on his wedding at the
end of the video he announces that all
streets lead to one thing and that they
will soon see each other Toretto however
it is not yet clear and the two will
appear together again in front of the
camera nearly a decade has passed since
James Cameron brought his movie avatar
to the cinemas and it became the most
successful movie of all time and even
though the most successful film of all
time is now Avengers endgame avatar has
made 3d film technology very popular in
the cinema there are now plans for four
sequels until 2027 but there is still a
lack of information on the films and the
first sequel will not be released for
another two years a newly released photo
now his fans a glimpse behind the scenes
the official Avatar Twitter channel a
picture was published that makes the
sequel a bit more tangible the headline
reads wave machines blazing fire and
James Cameron wielding a 3d camera just
another day on the set of the Avatar
sequence
it is also announced that producer John
Landau will continue to publish such
snapshots in the future but the focus is
now on the production of the two firms
avatar 2 & 3 which will be shot at once
to save production costs the second
movie will again feature check Sully who
traveled to Pandora 12 years ago and
joined the native people of Navi
together with his partner Knight theory
he has an 8 year old daughter but the
joy about the family happiness does not
last too long because under the
leadership of general art more the
resources development administration is
supposed to rapid aura of its resources
the actress Emperor thinking and so we
said Ana will be there again
in addition Steven Lang's main rival
Colonel miles coverage will returned new
on board will be among others Kate
Winslet Cliff Curtis Michelle Yeoh
and win diesel avatar 2 will be released
on December 15 2021 while its successor
avatar 3 will be released on December 20
2023 Travis Knight is known as the
director of the Transformers spin-off
bumblebee it has recently become known
that he will now also be in charge of
the video game adaption of Uncharted
after the previous director Dan
Trachtenberg has turned his back on the
project sony has already kept its
promise to find a successor for the
director's chair by the end of this
summer
Knight will definitely have a tight
schedule as the shooting with lead actor
Tom Holland is scheduled to start early
next year
finally there could be some peace and
quiet because behind the scenes a lot of
things went wrong during the last month
in addition Tom Holland is a relatively
young Nathan Drake similar to the video
game uncharted 3 drake's Deception the
film is about the live face of the
leading actor in which he meets Victor
Sullivan for the first time which
clearly influences his future actions
there's not much more to be said about
the still untitled movie but we will
certainly get more information before
the shooting starts a few weeks ago
Justin crawled from variety and build
the mega news that matrix 4 had been
decided not as a reboot or spin-off but
as a clear follow up to the origin
no films in the podcast my mom's
basement he announced that Warner
Brothers is allegedly looking for an
actor for a younger version of neo in
Metrix for as a verification is quite
difficult and Justin crawl troupe to be
fairly trustworthy in the past we assume
that Kroll is right but what does that
mean for the movie
what's clear so far Keanu Reeves and
carrie-anne moss have already been
confirmed but it's not yet clear whether
Laurence Fishburne will be on board
again as Morpheus this is where it gets
interesting because even before the
rumor about the young neo became known
as ever rumours that they were looking
for young Morpheus and also the name
Michael B Jordan often came up now there
are two possibilities why want to show
the original actress as well as a
younger version of them in one movie
either matrix four will be about time
travel in some way inside or outside the
matrix or there will be a second
timeline a matrix for that is no longer
connected to the original stars which
would allow possible sequels an exact
release that is not yet known but we
expect a release not before 2021
[Music]